l'ampleur et la nature des catastrophes
naturelles dans certaines régions et
sans précédent déclaré vladimir poutine
lors d'une réunion consacrée à la
gestion des conséquences liées aux feux
de forêts et aux inondations le
président russe a affirmé qu'il rôle
sauver quotidiennement des rapports sur
la situation en sibérie et en extrême
orient russe ravagées par les incendies
ainsi que sur le sud de la russie
victimes d'inondations écoutez n'ont
qu'à nice bien sûr nous voyons nous
comprenons et je le répète encore une
fois que l'ampleur et la nature des
catastrophes naturelles dans certaines
régions sont absolument sans précédent
il suffit de dire que dans le sud par
exemple il arrive que l'équivalent d'un
mois de précipitations tombent en
quelques heures mais si ce n'est aux
normes nationales
par contre en sibérie ou en extrême
orient les conditions naturelles
climatiques atmosphériques étaient
telles que les feux de forêt se sont
propagées rapidement dans des conditions
de sécheresse et de rafales de france
pour vladimir poutine ces catastrophes
naturelles montre à quel point il est
important de s'engager pour répondre aux
défis climatiques et environnementales
c'est tout cela montre une fois de plus
à quel point il est important de nous
engager profondément systématiquement et
à long terme en faveur de l'agenda
climatique et environnementale mais
aujourd'hui bien sûr nous nous
concentrerons surtout sur les tâches
pressante urgente
la dîmière poutine s'exprime quelques
jours après la parution d'une nouvelle
publication du groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat doux le mieux le giec qui a tiré
la sonnette d'alarmé face un changement
climatiques qui s'accélèrent selon le
giec l'activité humaine a contribué au
réchauffement climatique un niveau sans
précédent depuis deux mille ans